Okay.
Hello.
I am twelve minutes later than I said
I would be, but I did say I
would livestream picking the winners from the retweet
competition
to win some
Rawkode swag.
So we're gonna get started on that right
now.
I know I have already drawn the first
winner
because I had to make sure the software
works. You'll see I did this
just around five, six minutes ago.
So our first winner is
Hello, mister.
So we are going to draw another nine
of these.
I will reach out to everyone who has
drawn and get you sorted out with
with
did I say it was? T shirt and
a mug? I think it was the T
shirt and a mug. Alright. So congratulations to
winner number one.
I should probably
copy these down. Right?
Is just text editor. Winners.
Yeah.
Yeah. I'm so organized.
So when you pick another winner, it takes
me to some other
random
website.
Hey, Russell.
Fancy new theme.
Yeah. I'm working on updating the brand in
a little bit. Thanks for noticing.
It's so annoying. I just wanna pick 10
winners.
Okay.
Well, when things don't go to plan, retweet
picker winner.
We'll try one of the other ones from
earlier.
Hey for that. How's it gone?
Hey, Luke Shire.
This is gonna be the most uneventful stream
ever, of course. I'm only picking winners
for the competition.
Hey, Nuno. Nice to see you.
I don't know who won chip because the
software I was gonna use
wants me now to
sign up for something else and pay.
I can always pick these at random by
going through the tweets, so we're try not
to do that. We're just gonna try some
random software so I can get name more
names out of this.
License key.
Let's me turn into a live coding stream
where I write my own them retweet pecker
runner.
Let's try not to do that.
Authorize.
How many of these things am I gonna
have to authorize? I better remember to remove
them all.
Winners from retweet of a tweet.
Oh, that's the first winner.
You're all funny.
Let's see. My competition tweet now.
This should be easier.
No. I should be more prepared. This probably
is easy.
I'm just an idiot.
Okay.
Here's the tweet URL.
Let's drop this in here.
Get retweets for followers.
That's gonna pack a winner.
I don't know.
Oh, I think it's doing something.
Hopefully we have another winner.
Thomas Lab, you're funny. Let me move the
comments up. This will not be the same
length as a clustered stream.
Hell no.
Yes. Random in quotes.
Russell don't encourage me to build a tool.
And I don't know if Nuno is suggesting
the name for this tool, retweetie, but I
quite like it.
All right, so I think we've got a
second winner.
If I copy their username,
add it to the doc.
Can I pick another one?
Oh, I can. There we go. This is
working.
I think we're kicking.
Alright. Easy hockey nut. Another winner.
Let me change the font size on this.
We've got three so far.
What do you mean? No. No. It doesn't
show the retweet.
Oh, I think I know what you mean.
Just goes to the profile, doesn't it?
Yeah. I'll do some checking to make sure
the retweets exists just in case.
I think I was there.
So we'll just keep picking for now. I'll
do some due diligence, but hopefully they're all
legit.
And that would be a good way though.
Like, you could write a random tweet picker
just to get yourself
when competitions and then it doesn't it just
gives you usernames of your fake accounts rather
than actually anyone that retweeted.
That would be funny.
Alright.
We've got
one, two, three, four, five.
Yeah. Thomas Lavish rate. This is
only grabbing 100.
There actually weren't many more than a hundred.
I think it was a 23
over that as saying
this goes random
names from your followers. I don't think so
because
two of the accounts don't follow me. I
think it is using
this. Oh, it says does it retweets or
followers, but then it does count.
We have winners from retweets of a tweet.
Alright. Apparently, I have a 45 retweets.
Am I gonna have to write some software?
Alright.
Getting complicated.
Decisions.
Do it right at the software,
but then use the software which unbox therapy
used for a giveaway. What did they use?
Let me know.
So, I mean, I could continue with this.
My only concern is just that I don't
want anyone to be left out. And if
it's only using the first one hundred,
We have picked five winners thus far.
Look at that one. Yeah. One, two, three,
four, five.
Okay. Let's have a let's spend a couple
of minutes to see if I can find
another website that will do this legitly.
I'll add on more banners.
And then if I need to, I'll write
something later.
So let's see. Retweet,
I'll type
picker
winner
over 100. This is a common search term.
I'm sure someone's probably got some code on
Gout for this. Right?
We draw.
There's a gleam.
Also, this is an actual thing.
What's your pricing?
That reference another one. Right? Which I think
thank you for that. I really like the
new banner and profile logo too.
And we had the last branding since January,
so just trying to keep things a bit
more fresh.
Okay. So I did actually try to use
this one
and it didn't work. At least it made
me try to pay.
Yeah. So another winner and then it takes
me to this.
Hey.
What's that?
Twitter, please.
I have authorized so many of these things.
I'm gonna have to clean this up.
Sure.
Alright.
Check my email.
Important testing content. Yeah.
Contest name.
Competition
one. Because I'm sure I'll do more of
these.
For that, I've seen use
woobox.com.
Just trying to get me to write something
here. I think that that's that's a really
cool idea for another stream
would be to write something for this because
well, yeah, it would be fun. So I'm
not gonna do it today right now, but,
yeah, let's do that.
Because it'll give me an give
me an opportunity to expand experiment with some
new languages that we've able to play with
anyway. SIG is one that I really wanna
write something in, so this could be a
cool idea for that.
Alright. Let's load our entries.
How many winners are they gonna be? So
I said 10,
and then I did see if I go
over a hundred retweets, it would be another
10. So there's gonna be 20 winners in
total, but I'm only gonna do 10 today,
and then we'll do another 10
on Thursday or Friday. I'm thinking of doing
it maybe just before custard on Thursday.
So, yes, there will be 20 winners in
total, but 10 today.
Okay. Load the entries.
I understand.
Once per contest. Yes. Well, this contest is
now over, so just
load. Hold me to load.
There we go.
How do I
draw?
Is that what this button is? Not create,
import, make a draw.
Competition one.
That's in.
Do all 23.
But I wanna get two streams out of
it.
Let's see.
Depends how long it takes.
Alright. Okay. We'll do them all. Oh, I
can't.
I can do 10 because of this the
free plan that allows me to do 10.
So we've already drawn five. So I can
do 10 now. And then we'll do five
during clustered. How about that?
Pop is excluded from winning.
You will not be allowed a t shirt.
Anchor is telling me to follow my plan.
Yeah. I I think spun up with this
will be fun,
but I know people wanna win prizes.
We'll we'll do the 10 that the software
allows me to do then. That's 15. We'll
do five during clustered.
That gives me a better time to try
and write something to make this fun too.
And there's gonna be more giveaways, so please
don't stress. Gonna be loads of opportunities to
win t shirts. There'll be at least a
couple of giveaway every week. So just, you
know, follow me on Twitter. Subscribe to the
channel. Pay attention.
Closing date.
Now
the user must have a retweet publication.
Yes.
User must follow the no. You don't need
to follow me. If you retweeted, you can
you can win.
Russell's telling me just as if I'm right.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Let's do it. Let's stick
with the original plan.
Remind your checks allows you to take control
of it or just before you decide on
the winners after successfully passing our automatic checks.
I
don't need to check anything.
If you reach, we see the when yes.
I don't want bots to win.
According to what?
Sure. It seems like I don't have access
to this feature. Right? Okay. But no.
That's it. Save.
The previous four were not legit due to
unequal probability.
True.
Very true.
This got complicated quick this got complicated quickly.
They still retweeted the
yes. The odds
were slightly skewed with the hundred retweets.
There was a 23
retweets according to this.
The probability
is effective, but I'm gonna go with it.
This is a learning. I'm now learning loads
about giving Twitter giveaways now, so we're just
gonna have to deal with it for this
one and take it from there. Okay. Let's
draw.
So
the the test draw or final draw? The
test draw just be Ragen, have you your
name came up, but you weren't in the
final draw? That'd be funny.
Just give it to the people watching me
live right there.
It's a great idea.
Let's see what happens. I understand I can
only do this one final draw per contest
even if it's a test.
Yes. I will rate code for more runners.
Yes.
It does count quoted tweets
because it's Twitter.
Is that a terrible assumption?
Or it doesn't count quoted tweets because there
were 22 quoted tweets and a 24
manual retweets.
How can I come and this is only
showing me a 23
retweets?
So, really, all this software is shit.
Well, Russell, you win. I am gonna have
to write something. What I'm gonna do, I'm
gonna honor the first five draws. I'm gonna
honor the fives of this picks. We will
draw another 10 with software that I write,
hopefully, today or tomorrow.
We'll give some OEM custard, and it says
and as I said
earlier,
I'm just gonna keep giving the stuff away
anyway. So
if you don't want today, you will want
better version.
Let's just do it.
There are 13 people watching over there.
Not just on YouTube. I am streaming to
Twitter too.
Alright.
Coop Daly can't win. That's an organization.
Oh, well.
Let's copy
this.
At least I've got the names there even
if there is a big annoying graphic.
Now
we have our winners.
I don't think anyone is on the stream
right now.
I'm sorry about that.
That's a good call, Russell. Tell you what.
Yeah. Cube Daily can't win as an organization.
I thought they did retweet, so really I
should find that.
I get in here.
For Dan, post a link to your retweet
in a chat or your Twitter username.
I'll get you a t shirt,
and then we'll draw more names when we
have some software.
If you didn't win,
don't worry. Like I said, there is gonna
be a couple of t shirts every week
and mugs given away. So, you know,
watch the streams.
Curious man. Thank you for that.
You will you
will get one too.
Alright. I'm gonna call it there. This was
an absolute
disaster.
Bill Mulligan one. I am sure Bill will
allow me to redraw
his
So
yeah.
Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. You're getting a code
to stream.
So it seems I mean, I'm gonna do
a quick search on GitHub. There someone has
to have written this already.
This is just
this this should be so easy.
I mean, I know the Twitter API
gets a bad rap because there are so
many constraints on it, being able to pull
out retweets, pick pick
some at random
Should be easier than this. So, yeah, we're
gonna have some fun. And maybe we'll do
this cloud native and over engineer the heck
out of it. Half as a microservice that,
you know,
fills out retweets, puts them on to an
event queue and blah blah blah. Maybe maybe
we can have some fun.
Like I said, if you don't want today,
more coming soon. Thank you for watching this
completely random car crash of a stream.
But it's always fun to chat, and the
comments were great. They've been my day. So
have a awesome day. There's no stream today
on the Rawkode Academy, but we do have
a team version of Clustered tomorrow. So we
will see you then and I will be
giving away more t shirts tomorrow.
Anyway,
you're all wonderful. Have a great day.